let's talk a bit more about the latest
developments today we can get analysis
of the situation on the ground with
retired Air Vice Marshall Sean Bell who
is also advisor at Universal defense and
Security Solutions and Sean good to see
you again let's talk about and this
change of tact by President Putin when
it comes to Mario Paul this morning we
were thinking Mario Paul Could Fall by
this afternoon and now Vladimir Putin
has decided not to send his troops into
the steel works but to create a ring of
Steel around it effectively I think it's
most interesting you don't often see
Putin getting directly involved in
tactical details on the battlefield so I
think we've got to look beyond what what
is actually going on here I think it's
pretty evident that this is a very
difficult nut to crack for Russia at the
moment uh when Putin announced it he
talked about the impact on his Russian
forces that they were getting a bloody
nose doing it and it's a distraction
from his main effort and the other thing
is there are unconfirmed reports of
thousands of civilians still in that
area any assault on that would
inevitably highlight lots of Civilian
casualties whilst that hasn't been an
issue for Russia up to now given that
the world's media is focused on this I
suspect it wouldn't be helpful to his
War aims there is a risk of course by
moving his troops away is that you make
the remaining Russian troops static and
you therefore provide some initiative
potentially uh to the ukrainians and but
for me crucially whilst there is
Ukrainian resistance there it'll
continue to be a thorn in the side of
Russia and of course Putin can't claim
victory until he's
um until he's assuage finished that
threat off I think it's also a sign of
um Putin's frustration with the tenacity
and The Bravery of the Ukrainian forces
in there having been cut off for so long
no food no water no ammunition he fully
expected surrender or die there would
have only been one option and yet
they've chosen to fight on and I think
that's the really good example of the
military ethos of those Fighters that
they are service before self that they
are prepared to make the ultimate
sacrifice for the greater good and what
is the greater good here let's be clear
for every minute they have been tying up
Russian forces is it's a minute when
those forces can't move away it's
another minute where those forces
Russian forces can't get involved and
start targeting their brothers up to the
north and I think this is a really
amazing example of Bravery tenacity and
ultimately sacrifice yeah just one of so
many in terms of this decision by
President Putin about what happens at
the steel Works how does this affect the
overall campaign that they're they're
mounting in the east of the country well
I think it's exposed if we didn't know
before that clearly the Don
um the donbass region is the priority
for Putin he's throwing all his
resources at it we've had the mayor of
khaki reporting that there's been
shelling going on up to the north there
um just very recently I think most
western analysts thought Putin would
take another week or two to recover his
forces that were moored up in Kiev and
get them actually all refreshed and
resupplied ready for this new fight
unfortunately every day that goes by
provides the ukrainians another day to
recover get more Aid into the country so
it's always going to be a compromise I
think most western analysts believe that
Russia has gone quite early on this
offensive and also spread itself out
over a 300 mile front line which carries
a lot of risk if it works and they make
a decisive breakthrough that will be
interesting for the outcome but if it
doesn't work Russia could get yet
another malling I think what most
analysts agree though is whatever
happens we're facing a brutal battle
ahead in the days and weeks ahead